mastercard bought ciphertrace yesterday
so ciphertrace they developed tools that
help businesses and law enforcement root
out illicit digital currency
transactions they provide solutions for
some of the largest banks exchanges and
other financial institutions in the
world in june dan loeb's third point
ventures led a 27.1 million dollar
series b round and they also received
the board seat so why the hell is a
legacy card network like masterworks or
a master card
shout out masterworks uh mastercard
buying cypher trace well it gives
mastercard the ability to track over 300
over 900 cryptocurrencies uh it states
that it'll help its customers protect
themselves and comply with regulations
that they start to build out their own
digital currency offerings and the
acquisition as part of mastercard's
strategy in the digital asset space to
help provide customers merchants and
businesses with more choice in how they
move digital value now it's really
interesting because visa and mastercard
have actually been some of the more
forward-thinking legacy financial
players in this industry visa as we know
they bought a crypto punk they've been
all over stable coins with uh usdc they
were very early to trying to figure out
how to support on the cards uh spending
cryptocurrencies they also have the
block five bitcoin reward credit card uh
they've been doing things in bitcoin and
ethereum etc so pretty interesting
mastercard on the other hand has not
been as public about it but they do have
partnerships with gemiini bitpay uphold
and others uh they've created a brand
new platform to test and support central
bank digital currencies and the programs
they do have support the use of
blockchain technology nfts and select
stablecoins directly on its network so
we've got a couple of quotes i believe
from the players here first from the ceo
of cypher trace dave jevins we help
companies whether they are banks or
cryptocurrency exchanges government
regulators or law enforcement to keep
the crypto economy safe our two
companies share this vision to provide
security and trust throughout the
ecosystem we are thrilled to join the
mastercard family to scale cypher traces
reach across the globe pretty
interesting second quote that we have is
from the
president of cyber and intelligence at
mastercard who by the way just looks
like he'd be the president of cyber and
intelligence right like my guy like
let's rate the mustache i'm gonna go
with a nine out of ten pretty strong
real full 8.8 out of 10. 8.8 that's fine
that's a good absolutely killer that's a
cop mustang that's
definitely a cop mustache who's that guy
no that is a that is not only a cop that
is i'm trying to be an undercover agent
but i everyone on the block knows i'm a
cop mustache shows up says i got my cup
of coffee in my gun don't move put your
hands to the sky
that mustache is all time uh ajay bahala
aj aj aj ajay i don't know how you
pronounce it uh with the rapid growth of
the digital asset ecosystem damn i can't
read today like like forget ebenezer
scrooge i'm out here like floyd
mayweather i can't read
green eggs and ham shout out to anyone
on the internet uh quote with the rapid
growth of the digital asset ecosystem
comes the need to ensure it is trusted
and safe our aim is to build upon the
complementary capabilities of mastercard
and ciphertraits to do just that makes a
lot of sense here's my take i don't have
any answers more so than anybody else
but my general take is the following one
let's take bitcoin bitcoin is a
transparent ledger it means that every
single transaction is done publicly and
you can see who is the sending wallet
who's the receiving wallet how much is
the amount when was it done etc if
there's any messages in there you could
also see that as well now when you have
a public ledger it does some really
positive things one is you can use that
public blockchain to make sure that
there's no double spending
two is that you can ensure that every
single transaction is seen it's
transparent on a public ledger the third
thing is that it makes it really hard
for criminals to do nefarious things
because every single transaction is
logged publicly on top of that what it
does is it drastically increases the
ability for law enforcement to be able
to look at the public blockchain see who
is transacting with who how much when
etc and so if they deem that somebody
has done something illicit they can
actually track the funds on the public
blockchain all of that is pro law
enforcement pro transparency pro
accountability the downside to that is
it drastically increases the financial
surveillance capabilities it drastically
removes financial privacy for those that
are using the system and it really
really opens up a conversation around
what are your personal rights and
individual liberties and how can you
still maintain financial privacy while
using a great technology like the
bitcoin blockchain so what ends up
happening is there are a couple of
different ways that you can um you know
kind of address this one is there's a
ton of stuff that gets done off chain
that ends up then getting written onto
the bitcoin blockchain the second thing
is that you can actually use things like
coinjoin or others that have a way to
somewhat mask or make it more difficult
to track and trace uh cryptocurrencies
there's questions about the legality of
that but that is an option today and
then lastly is you can choose not to use
the system which i think over
time will become increasingly more and
more difficult
i recently had a conversation he's going
to be really excited that i'm gonna say
this right now uh because he spent quite
a bit of time showing me this uh with
zuko who is the creator of zcash and
zuko was showing me that zcash which
uses something called zk snarks and some
other cryptography uh basically has a
way to send a
transaction let's say i'm sending it to
john where we can shield
who the sender is who the recipient is
and what amount and any message that's
within the transaction it's shielded but
the transaction still occurs and you can
insure on the blockchain that it doesn't
get double spent
pretty interesting now over time is that
possible that bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies could take that
technology and start to incorporate it
yes will they do it it would require an
upgrade it would require a lot of
changes to be made so
in the past there's not been an appetite
to do that but things like that the
privacy technology is pretty interesting
um and so we'll see how that kind of
permeates when it comes to companies
like this there are some things that
fall in the regulatory bucket um you
know i'm an investor in a company called
elementos there's cypher trace there's a
bunch of these um and the regulatory
standpoint is they're trying to prevent
money laundering they're trying to
prevent all sorts of nefarious or
malicious activity on top of that there
is a law enforcement capability so
somebody stole something from john we
can track the actual funds we can go
from a law enforcement standpoint and
use the blockchain to do that and then
lastly is there's an analytics component
to it as well and so when you think from
an analytics standpoint if we have a
public blockchain somewhere to be on
chain metrics we can do all sorts of
analysis to really start to understand
what is happening who's doing it and if
that trend is going up down staying
stagnant et cetera really really
interesting when you have a public
blockchain everything that it empowers
john what do you think you did a lot of
work on this in terms of understanding
this what do you think about the cypher
trace
acquisition by mastercard it's a win-win
why
both companies benefit greatly from it
mastercard gets to
integrate with cypher trace right they
now run their business as the digital
economy grows cypher trace should be
more
valuable to
uh you see that visa and mastercard are
the two biggest players in this space
right they are i think some of the most
innovative players in the space as well
just based off their way to kind of
adapt to the digital economy that's
growing um was it mastercard does the
gemini card right and then visa does the
block fight card so they they understand
what's going on in this space uh it adds
more validity to this space this this
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies clearly
aren't going anywhere anytime soon um or
probably in the future at all so it's
it's cool to see um but of course
they're innovating around this of course
they're looking at companies and
acquiring companies uh it's pretty cool
to see dan point or dan loeb's
was it uh third point ventures right
yesterday's company third point ventures
yeah um
they i'm assuming they still retain some
equity in the company but i love it win
for him as well pull in any thoughts so
i just i wanted to see how much venture
capital they've raised it looks like 45
million and they're backed by third
point
um
and west wave capital and galaxy digital
and aspect ventures
interesting that mastercard hadn't made
an investment before buying it typically
these like mastercard visa they like
invest a little bit see how it goes and
then it becomes an acquisition target
i'm curious john did you find how much
they bought it for no it was an
undisclosed amount so no one knows but
the two parties involved
so
do we think that and the irs when they
come for the taxes yeah
the two parties in the irs no
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you